another man and mama june's life
justin so now we know that she recently
got married to justin at a georgia house
so were you guys surprised
let me tell you how this all happened
okay let me tell you how we found out
okay so we went we were just kind of
back back out of town for summer or
something like that we just got back to
town i went to check my post office box
check my post office box and there was a
letter in there and it was addressed to
her and of course any time
it's maybe legal or whatever but anytime
she's like oh just open it up and just
let me know what it is you know so so i
opened it up and it was from the
courthouse so i'm assuming because this
was also around the time that we were we
have not finished court yet you know
with the custody stuff and everything
this was like a literally a week before
everything was about to be finalized in
court so i was like okay maybe they're
just letting her know about the court
date
opening up and sure enough it was a
receipt addressed to her for a marriage
certificate i didn't say anything i did
not say nothing at all so you were
waiting for her to i was really waiting
genuinely i was waiting for her to be
like okay y'all i went up and got
married
never never nothing like that i don't
know if it was because maybe she was
very ill with me about the custody thing
and having to pay child support that she
was like well i don't feel like you need
to be a part of that
okay
but um when we left court the following
week i ended up i told him i was like
i'm gonna say something to her
i said because she wanted to just sit
here pitching for a fiat in the
courtroom about you know whatever i said
then
i'm gonna ask her about it being married
and sure enough we got out to the
parking lot and i said well
congratulations on being married i got
the receipt in the mail
and she was like no no no no i didn't
get married i didn't get married she
still denied it and up until
i would say right before i had the twins
when she admitted to it
she didn't even physically tell me well
were you hurt that you weren't invited
to the courthouse for the wedding i'm
not really hurt um if she feels like we
didn't need to be a part of that then
so be it elana what were your feelings
on the wedding um i wasn't hurt i was
more in shock because my mama always
said that
she would never get married she would
never go off and just get married with
somebody she was scared of marriage like
to say the least and now she went off
and just got married with this dude she
hadn't even known a whole year yet right
on their six-month anniversary
but she and i mean for somebody who just
because she knows who love is and this
is true
but everybody like and she tells me that
with everybody and it's it's different
with this one it's different with this
one it was different with gina it was
different with sugar bear you know it
was now it's different with justin and
i'm not saying justin's a bad guy by any
means but i also don't know him that
well yeah i said do you all have a
relationship with justin and do you
foresee yourself ever being a family
with him mama june i really i'm not
gonna speak on him
like i said i really don't i genuinely
don't know him i don't know him enough
to be like okay he's no good
um
none of that i've only known him by his
action and so far his actions haven't
really shown
okay i want to be a part oh really you
know
because i mean they live in alabama now
she was like they're not living down the
street no ma'am
no ma'am
we don't know where she's living we
still
so
she confirmed that she lives in alabama
but um she was staying delaware
and then once again that was another
thing just like the marriage thing that
was kind of like a fly by the night
thing in the middle of night she
not really in the middle of the night
but like just randomly she pops up and
tells me that she was moving because you
know they have some stuff to take care
of with him and his
stuff with the law and stuff like that
so
okay yeah
saga
[Music]
i got a whole lot of sweet tea today oh
my gosh now now that she's in alabama
how are things going with the child
support is it
she no cooperating i will say she she's
very much been cooperative about it
does she want to give me 800 a month no
ma'am she does not does she have an
attitude every time she goes to send it
yes she does but does she send it she
sends it yes
do you feel like you know too much
sometimes in regards to like
what your mom is thinking and doing and
no i don't think i know too much i'm
actually really glad that like pumpkin
like
lets me like she doesn't treat me like
i'm a little kid and be like no we need
to keep this from alana so she doesn't
know about it i was raised like that my
entire life my mom always like
not her drug stuff she never really hid
that from us just in case something
happened to her
but everything else was just kind of
like a sugar coat over every single
thing and i hated it so i knew when i
had kids or even when i got alana
i didn't i wanted to try to break all
that stuff i wanted you to be in the
know of what's always going on because
if something was to happen
or
anything really anything was to happen
or somebody wants to say something alana
knows firsthand before
anybody else knows
[Music]
you